tell me what's going on in Sudan as far
as Brits are concerned
well there is a situation there of chaos
and enormous violence and the absolute
number one requirement is to get a
ceasefire heavy weapons are being used
in built-up circumstances this is
absolutely appalling and that's why
every sinew of the International
Community is being bent to try and stop
the fighting get these two sides to lay
down their weapons go back to barracks
and a proper ceasefire is should be
maintained so far there have been a
number of attempts at a ceasefire but
virtually all of them have failed almost
immediately so we can't get the Brits
out without ceasefire well we will do
everything we can and I mean everything
to get our British citizens out an
extremely successful but complicated
operation was conducted yesterday
morning which got the diplomats out we
have a specific duty of care for the
diplomats but I must stress that these
diplomats were in acute danger because
the guns were either side of the British
Embassy and the British residents and we
got them out as fast as we could as did
the Americans get their diplomats out
and that was a successful and
brilliantly executed operation and our
attention as it has always been over the
last week since we went into 24 7 crisis
mode on the Sudan situation Our
intention always has been to facilitate
the exit of our own citizens as soon as
it is safe to do so when might that be I
cannot answer that question all I can
tell you is that every single option is
being explored in detail and the moment
that it is possible to change the travel
advice and move them we will
how can you bring out diplomats but not
citizens well we have a duty of care to
every British citizen but we have a very
specific duty of care to our own
diplomats they are our staff and as I
say they were in acute danger diplomatic
premises had been specifically targeted
target targeted citizens not in extreme
danger well they are and I hope they are
most of them in much less danger than
the diplomats were where the Diplomat
where the diplomats were being attacked
diplomatic premises in sardum in
Khartoum were being deliberately
targeted and they were in acute danger
and that is why we took the decision
that we did
with respect Minister the first
um
first thing that any government has to
do is ensure the safety of its Nationals
its citizens you're saying that you can
bring out some that are more important
to you than others you're going to tell
me that's not what you're saying but
that's how I'm interpreting it this
morning
well I don't think that is the right
interpretation uh clearly the British
government cares for all its citizens
all around the world and it gives the
right travel advice to them and it does
everything it can to protect them but we
have a specific duty of care a legal
duty of care to our own staff and our
diplomats but I want to emphasize that
it was the Diplomatic community in
Khartoum that was specifically being
targeted we had diplomats being held up
at gunpoint some of them were attacked
their premises broken into and so there
was a very specific threat to the
Diplomatic community and that is why we
took the decisions that we did to
extract them and I think this is a very
difficult operation thank goodness
they're out and they're now in
air-conditioned bosses on their way home
which is fantastic there's an eight
there's a guy that was speaking to us on
Twitter he's 80 year old mum went to
Sudan to see family and was should have
been on her way back now she's not she's
trapped because of the fighting children
of trapped because of the fighting 400
British Nationals thousands of dual
Nationals are still trapped because of
the fighting it's your government's
responsibility our government's
responsibility to get them out as soon
as possible you're saying you don't know
when that might be I am saying that I'm
saying but what I'm also saying is that
everyone is trapped there the situation
is common across a cartoon
the position across Khartoum is
extremely dangerous and that is why we
advise people to stay indoors whenever
they can of course if they feel that
they can move safely they must make
their own uh judgment but the British
government can only give that advice but
I want to emphasize to you that we are
looking at every single opportunity to
help them to evacuate and we will take
any opportunity that presents itself to
do so they feel their own minister well
the situation is what it is I can't
pretend that it isn't but what I can
tell you is that we will do everything
we can to support them all those who
register with us and we've been
encouraging people to do so should
receive at least one message every day
unfortunately not all these messages are
getting through because of the
atmospherics in cartoon but I emphasize
to you that our concern is for our
citizens the government has been in
crisis mode on this working through day
and night for virtually a week now and
we are doing everything we can and will
do everything we can to get them out how
much danger do they need to be in for
you to decide that an airlift is the
Right Way Forward well we keep all the
options under review we are conscious of
the danger they are in all the time and
we will do and we will danger and we
will do of course there are so there's a
war zone there there are people using
heavy weapons in the capital city of
Sudan so we will do everything we can to
help them that is possible and may I say
as as one of the ministers who's been
doing this the government is working
seamlessly across all the different
parts of government that are involved
and I know that everyone is working to
try and get them out as soon as we can
and the reason I ask you that is because
you said they you suggested that they
were in less danger than the diplomats
and I wondered how you quantify that
danger well I quantify the danger
because the British residents and the
British Embassy was caught between the
lines of the combatants that was an
incredibly dangerous situation
mercifully most of the citizens are not
in exactly that position but because
they of their location and because they
were diplomats they were in a very
specific and acute danger but let me
emphasize that we are trying to look
after everyone key thing that has to
happen is the ceasefire and we're
working diplomatically across the United
Nations across the International
agencies the regional Partners the major
powers in Europe and elsewhere we are
working with our allies to try and
secure the ceasefire because that is the
critical thing that has to happen so the
Brits all have to hide under the bed
until that ceasefire's in place so the
Brits should take the travel advice that
we have issued we've updated it this
morning they should take that travel
advice and we will do everything we can
to help them so that is hiding under the
bed until a ceasefire well as I say that
we will do everything we possibly can to
help them in every way we can and in the
meanwhile where possible they should
stay indoors and wait but you can't do
anything until it sees fire from what
you're saying well we will do everything
we can including uh before a ceasefire
if we can successfully do it but let me
make this point yesterday the Turks
organized a convoy they had three muster
points where they were encouraging their
people to come to two of those Master
points were shot up during the time they
were assembling this is incredible
indeed the Germans are coming in after
the French and after us and they are
moving uh some of their people but I
should emphasize that the number of
Germans who are there is very very much
smaller than the number of Brits